[Music]
Hello how are you greetings such and Jaramillo
with your informative brief for today Tuesday
August 17 Governor Steve Sexto
would make an important announcement yesterday
those high capacity places
will now have the option of requiring
their attendees to be vaccinated if
you are vaccinated  so you don't have to
wear a mask those who only
have one dose can attend but
must still wear a mask
under 12 can't get
the kobe vaccine so must wear
a mask those who are
eligible but haven't been vaccinated can't
actually attend proof of cob vaccination is now required
and company
announced non-home salary employees have
until oct 15 to get
vaccinated all new hires
need to show proof of
vaccination starting 30  August
those who are not vaccinated must
submit proof of weekly detention
and if still  you haven't gotten the vaccine we
tell you that there will be some clinics
for this week las vegas' being a daughter
offers a morning from eight thirty to one
in the afternoon also tomorrow there will be another one
in cárdenas de la tropicana near
mount vista from 5 to 8  of the
generic night without offering vaccines on
Friday from 10 to 5 in the afternoon
while the high school of antxo will give a
clinic on Saturday from 9 to 2 in the afternoon and
now we turn to the weather forecast
today we will have temperatures
reaching 106 degrees for  the valley
the winds return to stay until tomorrow
with chances of rain for
thursday we will return to a sunny day in the
city with a maximum of 97 degrees the
three digits will return but until
sunday beautiful day you greet them tal and
jaramillo and this was your brief
informative edition in Spanish
[Music]